Hallo, mein Name ist Alice und ich komme aus
Schottland, also bin ich hier, weil ich
Deutsch lernen möchte und ich bin ein absoluter Anfänger.
Eigentlich ist mein Anreiz, bis August ein B1 zu bekommen,
weil Easy German eine
Sommerschule veranstaltet, die ich sehr mag  teilnehmen möchte,
und die Idee ist, dass ich hier sein werde, um
das, was ich auf Deutsch gelernt habe,
an euch weiterzugeben, damit wir zusammen lernen können,
also kann der Beginn einer Sprache
extrem entmutigend sein, weil du natürlich
nichts verstehst und du  Ich kann nicht
einmal einen Satz aneinanderreihen, also
versuche ich, einen Weg zu finden, das Eis zu brechen,
wenn Sie eine Sprache lernen, und ich
denke, ich habe eine gute Methode, und
diese Methode ist, dass Sie wahrscheinlich schon
davon gehört haben  bevor Sie es vortäuschen, bis Sie es geschafft haben, also
tun Sie es vor, bis Sie es geschafft haben, und jetzt
können Sie diese Methode offensichtlich in
vielen Bereichen Ihres Lebens anwenden, sei es in Ihrem
Job, Ihren Beziehungen, vielleicht Ihren
Bestrebungen, aber wenn es um das
Sprachenlernen geht, ist es äußerst nützlich
Sprachenlernen ist also eigentlich
alles  Selbstvertrauen Ich würde sagen, am
Anfang des Sprachenlernens steht das
Selbstvertrauen, die
Mimik und die Körpersprache von Menschen zu lesen,
und eigentlich ist alles sehr
instinktiv, weshalb ich es liebe,
eine Sprache zu lernen, also werde ich Ihnen vier
grundlegende deutsche Wörter geben, die ich denke
sind sehr wichtig und wenn du
ein Gespräch auf Deutsch vortäuschen willst und das
ist Ghana, das bedeutet genau das ist deine
Liga, was natürlich US
bedeutet, was bedeutet, okay oder wirklich ein Shad, was bedeutet,
oh schade, schade, also diese vier Wörter
finde ich perfekt  Wenn du
nichts verstehst
, gehen wir jetzt auf
die Straße und
versuchen, ein Gespräch
mit einer deutschsprachigen Person zu führen und
das ganze Gespräch nur mit diesen
vieren vorzutäuschen  Worte lassen sie glauben, dass ich weiß,
wovon ich spreche, und ich verstehe
sie, also lasst uns versuchen, es vorzutäuschen, bis
wir es auf Deutsch schaffen, okay, also bin ich hier in
den Straßen von Berlin bereit  um die
vier Wörter zu verwenden, die du
weißt, ich bin so nackt, um ein falsches
Gespräch auf Deutsch zu führen, um dir zu zeigen, dass
wir es vortäuschen können, bis wir es schaffen, also habe ich
gerade einen Mann kennengelernt, der sein eigenes
Fitnessstudio eröffnet, und ich  Ich werde ihn fragen,
was sein Konzept ist, ohne offensichtlich
die Antwort zu verstehen, ein Vas ist ein
Diner Fitness-Konzept, wenn das
Konzept ein Elektrologe ist mooskaa Screening
, das ist abwertend, das ist die Stimulation,
die der Mosconi stärkere Hongkong Ananda
China aus dem Sturm importiert, okay, und die
Entwicklung dessen, was Vantage bedeutet, Routine
Putzen, wie ich sah, intensiviert meinen Geist, also
probierte ich ein Fitnessstudio an
, aber anomischer Personal Trainer.
Ich bin Amita, mein dajia, heißer Mann,
maximal ein Nebler und überzieht den Satelliten
zu em
Lippen 10-ish Maxim mit Dosen Dosen für
Morgen über Dimensionen eigenen Dosen
Incan und erbrechen ein Maschenbier auf Männerzeitschriften,
das ist ein Übel und Leck auf
seinen Reifen vi  a oh yeah das ist
Angriff bigand
keine Energie nicht viel möglich
Sitzung Danke Shanna Mission genial
Pellicer Zielseite max - ich bin Lippen 10
ich bin Lipson Markt in ab nicht er klopfte
aber gerührt Onkel ist als Schulabgänger
erwähnt  Faultier oder hast du so
traurig angefangen noch dein jetzt schwul beendet Martins
lange Rauchmaschine ist Mamas Masala oft
Mönche und a la época Kopfstil ist nicht
Mord
Monzas Dorf, also kommt Carrie zufällig
gerade aus dem Büro,
also ich '  Ich werde versuchen, ein
Gespräch mit ihr auf Deutsch zu führen. Ich habe
Cat Am Velia-Zielstellen neben einem
Molybdän gesehen. Marcus einzige Person.
Ja, hol deine Matrix raus. Weißt du, was heute
großartig ist
?
em up ershon
neu entzünden alle in die Enge getrieben ich bin verrückt Boiler
ja blase ihn tief Luton der - innerlich
abgedroschen nervös ist alles was ich gehört habe war nicht
schwer zum legen
ja und das ist wirklich groß verrückt vor
Anstrengung Danke Shankari
aber bald ist Ellis so  Los geht's, wir haben
versucht zu fälschen, und so haben wir
uns auf Deutsch
unterhalten, von dem ich eigentlich gar nichts verstanden habe